I'm a tried wife. I got married at 18.
My husband is the main breadwinner,
and I'm pregnant with our first child.
What would I do if my husband died?
This question
I've been asked a lot by naysayers and just curious individuals.
So welcome to part two of my series on emergency protocols.
I think it's really important to have different supports.
I guess I would call it in place that would help you manage life
if a catastrophe like my husband dying were to happen.
So if something were to happen to my husband,
I would go back and live under my father's roof.
So it's really important
to maintain healthy relationships with my parents,
not just for this, but obviously
for all the other benefits
of having a healthy relationship with your parents.
When we got married,
they already told Andrew that if something happened to him,
they would take me back under their roof,
provide for me financially,
and help me with that transition.
I think it's also really important to have a good church family
to help with childcare, meals,
financially, if needed.
Um, that is what the church is for.
So we have a really amazing church family that I know would do that.
I've seen them do that in other families lives.
So that is another really important support.
Have, I think also good relationships with in laws and siblings.
In laws. We know our neighbors,
people that we could call over who Lived really close
in case I needed help with, like,
heavy lifting stuff or if my car didn't start.
Lastly, having solid marketable skills.
And I cannot stress this enough.
I have worked really hard a lot of my life
to develop marketable skills.
I also know many people in our local community.
If entrepreneurship wasn't working,
I am well networked in our local community,
and I could get a job with a local business.
Like and follow for the next part of my emergency protocol series.